الدبابات غربيه الصنع وصلت دفعات منها
لاوكرانيا لكن استخدامها في بدايه الهجوم
المضاد غير محتمل بحسب تقرير النيوزك قبل
يومين اعلنت المانيا ان اوكرانيا استلمت
18 دبابات دبابات اثنين الى جانب الذخيره
وقطع الغيار ومركبتين انقاذ مدرعتين برلين
اضافت انه بنهايه العام الحالي ستكون
ثمانون دبابه اخرى من طرز اقدم متاحه
للاستعمال في اوكرانيا لكن نقلت عن خبراء
عسكريين قولهم ان فعاليه الدبابات تعتمد
على عده عوامل في ساحه المعركه من بينها
الطقس الطقس السيء لا يناسب هذه الدبابات
لثقل وزنها ما قد يجعلها تعلق في الوحل
الامر سيؤدي لجعل حركتها على طرق غير
ممهده امرا صعبا للغايه انتظار تحسن
الظروف الجويه سيمنح الجيش الاوكراني فرصه
الدبابات في اي موقع وربما ايضا تدريب
المزيد من الجنود عليها وبحسب المحللين قد
تختار اوكرانيا عدم استعمال دبابات لوبارد
وتشالنجر وان تحاول اولا اختراق الخطوط
الروسيه على العكس من هذا الراي قال
القائد السابق القوات الامريكيه في اوروبا
بن هاتجز ان تفوق الدبابات الغربيه على
نظيرتها الروسيه ستعطي اوكرانيا افضليه
خلال الهجوم المضاده واعتبر المسؤول
السابق ان الدبابات هذه يمكنها ان تشكل
حاجزا مصفحا يصعب اجتيازه وان تكسر خطوط
الدفاع الروسيه للتقدم في مختلف الجبهات
نتحدث طبعا عن زابوريا خرسون وايضا جزيره
القرن
[موسيقى]